因為我每次拍短視頻的時候
我拿起來就拍不給自己思考的機會
然後你們還搞了個聲音時的公司
因為讓我花點實驗性,思考完了
因為這是我叫不緊張
娘怕你同學
我叫不緊張二
怎麼會叫娘怕你再成長
因為我從小就不是一個特別守規矩的人
從小我也也不懂男孩一樣
在跟爺爺長的
然後回家之後
跟爸媽也覺得說
我是一個小男孩的性格
你們別束縫
所以上高中的時候
我就特別特別想去註校
不想跟爸媽在一起
高中畢業那一年的時候
我就會覺得說
不想我要考一個李嘉罪院的學校
我就在地圖上選了罪院的武漢
到現在位置都很判斷
你去的那個地方也很丟判
然後到現在位置
雖然三十多歲了
然後願望還是想要離開家
因為爸媽把我從武漢抓回去
抓回內蒙古了
這個是我特別特別崩潰了一個點
所以就一直想要逃離越來的家鄉
不是他不好
我明白
是自己可能就更希望有一個
自由自在的狀態
然後希望有一個自由自在的發展空間
你現在還和父母注意話嗎
還和父母注意話
所以其實是有很多自己想做的事情
對
因為會互相影響
你現在要如果要離開的話
你父母會會不同意嗎
不會因為我找了一個外地對象
好吧
你不會是為了離開他找了個外地對象
有這個因素在
我覺得我第一次連心
當時你連蠻是要去得到
是視頻
我覺得是最後沒去
然後還有蠻活的
對
因為年輕當時的那個一針建選的建議
你大概有百分之一的可能
盡得到這個答案雖然很一針建選
就是很扎心
但是他是準確的
然後確確實是不可能實現
因為人家要的是你的結局
你的作品
這個人是要用作品說話的
所以也是在那一次的經歷裡面
我發現我的簡力上面
沒有作品
對
然後很痛苦
就在家地上都套了
好幾天那種
然後痛靚思痛覺得說
我對我對我對做點什麼
就是說我們今天的主題
說
打發就做一件小事
其實當時我說你去的話
就是百分之一
但我還是鼓勵你去
對你特別鼓勵我去做這個投檢力
對
明知道要失敗
但我也要去
過程會被結果可能會更重要
然後特別感謝你的那個件
也讓我讓我很清楚的
那時候認識到自己
這個是促使我後面
做了很多很多嘗試的一個原因
我愛吃過你家的養腿
小賣乘吧
但是那個事後來不做了
對吧
那個事到現在為止
他還存在一個現下店
我現在不做的一個原因
是我清楚的認知到他的局限性
就是他除了有訂閱於他
他還有一個季節屬性
特別明顯
所以我覺得他不是一個好生意
我就放棄
你中間做了幾個這樣的
不是好生意
養肉算一個
然後酸奶
酸奶
我也是吃過
其他的時間
就是在帶小火瓣去做這個黃豆直播
你取得最高光的時候
是什麼時候
第一個我覺得是今年
八月份之後
就是您從沒山回來
看了您的那個小寶桶
養篇文章
一個是寫給在路上
隨便聊聊一句那篇
就是第一篇小寶桶
然後還有一篇是最好的理論那一篇
這兩篇是對我影響最大的
然後突然感覺自己
人多二賣被打通了
就用護死為
所以我做的短視頻
就是根據您問的那四個問題
我試誰
我有什麼我才問那些坑
我有什麼經驗能分想的
我把那個書裡了大概有三千多字
然後您說這個最好的理物
一定是針對一個人
送給養三三
就是送給養三三的
然後我送給加尾
就是送給加尾的
所以您看到我的那個視頻
每一個視頻背後都有一個
滿種的人
就是針對你一個人送的
你現在最多的
不妨講是多少
應該是個二十七萬
二十七萬
當然我還不止一條
現在是發了十一條視頻
還有十二條視頻
然後幾乎每一條都破萬步伐
所以其實每一條視頻
其實背後都是針對的
某一個人
然後再說
對
有一個氣急
我覺得我能知道
他們的問題點
我們每天一起去做
負盤這個動作
負盤的時候
三三有一個通連
加尾有一個通連
我就根據他們的通連
然後就好我解決過
我就給他發出來
這其實是一個非常好的方法
我自己在直播的時候
比如說
我到十分鐘回答問題
誰問了一個問題
然後這個問題的話
他是一個很普適的問題的時候
我其實就針對這個人
回答一個問題
然後當時就錄音了
把那個錄音的那種
就變成我們心球的一部分了
然後
這裡面會選擇一個
就是遊戲出現這個問題
然後就直接拍攝片
所以其實是非常非常順暢的
這個是拍攝片
一個非常有用的方法
現在可能
我們會場裡面百分之五十的
老貨集不知道怎麼拍攝片
就看這兩篇文章就夠了
真的
就是你給的那個答案是非常細緻的
聽話叫做
是八月份開始拍
對 八月份開始拍
五個月
然後基本上拼片都過了
總結一下方法論吧
我不是第一次拍短視頻
第一條短視頻
應該是兩三年前拍的
那時候拍的很想
就是我試誰
然後我在哪
我也拍過那種活動
我也拍過
情緒類的短視
都拍過都常識過
然後我發現了一個點
就是我特別特別有多實行
我拍完了我會去看數據
數據不好了
我就會受打擊
因為我真的是一個普通人
就俗人一個了
我怎麼可能不受打擊
我明月這麼努力
是吧
還還不好的反饋
但是今年之後
我覺得有一個心態改變了
我尤其是跟著
您的那兩篇小毛頭
去做這個事情的時候
我會發現我有一個
測試形態
這篇文章行不行
我發數據是意識
這個短視頻的行不行
反正我是送給
這一個人的禮物
這個心意我送到了
就可以了
數據是給我反規用的
不是來邀請我的
然後還有一個點是
公開工作
測試形態
加公開工作
等於瘋狂疊帶
我們五個人是每一天都在復判
就是堅持了兩年
七月份的時候
我們把這個東西放到的線上
有一個特別可笑的原因
一個月要說
要說我們三日都開前的
同學會議會員
結果就越來越多的小伙
去關注到我們的這個
復判的這個事情了
然後甚至我們每週二
都會搞一個
就趁著您直播人手
因為不丟臉上
然後我們那個
你以為我盡頭
趁著您人手
我說我的人怎麼變少
趁著
趁著您直播的時候
我們直播家人腳
然後我們就
幾個人開始互話
所以大家就是在這種氛圍裡面
就會問我們說
你們的氛圍很好
然後怎麼才能加入你們
然後這種聲音就會越來越多
越來越多
那時候我們就突然意識到
我們是不是有一個產品
叫復判賠萬一用
就是這個產品就
慢慢自己出來的
是大家推動的
特別好
我覺得這個分享特別好
我唯一的一個建議
就是你們的直播不要
剛剛還在直播
一個是和我衝突
我會害怕
另外一個原因是
什麼呢
就是我覺得
應該讓更多的人看見
對你們來說
法而是更好的事情
因為這個才是
彪定
爬不離開的
原本的音樂
因為我們是每天
每天都都不怕
對
然後加為
也跟我說的一點是
如果沒有這個環境
他沒有辦法
建華的這麼快
對
所以越大流不越
就是你錯誤家
反思等於進步
最這個方法就是特別好的
當你不得的測試的時候
其實你是成長歲
他不是說我因此成敗
我因此出去了以後
失敗了
失敗了以後
對我內心是打擊的
然後再去做
慢慢一直立即消磨了
但是我測試就是
其實是成長
我做了以後
發現有一個問題
然後去調整他
然後再去進化
再調整再進化
照這個分享下去
其實我們成功的概率
會非常的高
就算這個事沒有做成
其實我們的人
我們人是心花了
對
我就感覺我
因為一直前面是
我卡點在的
甚至很多時候卡住我了
我甚至會兩三個月
沒有辦法繼續行動
甚至有的時候
會有一年的這種體用
職期
大家好
太好了
我們特別喜歡聽
譽門的時候
來說兩個字
要是高上我開心一下
第一個是在我
去得到那個用片
那一次
再有一次就是
我想在武漢買房子
那可能就是房價的頂點
然後但是因為自己的信用卡
好像有三次與其
沒賣成
然後也是猜的狗失怨
感謝於其
然後信用卡沒賣成
就是一件事
當時兩件事
是跌價大集
就覺得完了
這輩子
就握在這個小地方
然後沒出路了
然後自己在家跑了七天
躺在地上
照亮
出了個電子
怎麼走出來的
我朋友過推薦了兩本書
一本是
單瓶的時間美貴
然後一本是
張淚的價值
我還有是價值信訪
你要是出書
找點書
我會拿到
是價值信訪
然後就拿到這兩本
書之後
突然就覺得
我可能要學學投資了
然後在網上
帥到胡子格的視頻
好多
然後那時候
您的直播
和短視頻
只因我出來的
可能您不知道
您只是
不斷地在做
您該做的這個事
沒事
我知道
因為我從收到的羊肉
和酸海的人
我知道了那個事
分享一個
您認為這麼一路走過來
您認為很重要
但是被大多數老婆
你們忽略的
認知
或者是方法
都可以
就是
不斷地做
我覺得
我的個人的問題
是前幾年
就是看書看得太多
就不做
我今年
為什麼在下半年
跌帶的速度
特別快的一個原因
是一直在持續做
雖然
我真的覺得
我自己挺笨的
可能數個月
才產出了十來條
就很好
因為認真
打摩一款產品
其實這個時候
已經不再說
我為了是
跟我講怎麼樣
其實我剛開始的時候
可以把時間拉長
就是一週的時間
認真地去做
這麼一個產品
然後再去復盤
再去總理
再去開心
對
所以我們就是
逼逆逼自己
潛力無限
我就發現
好像之前
一個禮拜做的事
現在兩天也行了
對
所以我們把那個
方法叫
爬金森
爬子
還有什麼要喝
然後你們不重的嗎
沒有
就是多做
然後多復盤
我覺得復盤的
力量很大
是
尤其是對思考
因為我之前
就見過你
之前我就聯合買
中間做的很多
過程都知道
我是能看到
不過你現在拍短視頻的
那個狀態都很好
然後去上復盤
加上Budding
旁邊和
問題
就很棒
謝謝胡子哥
好
謝謝